يزداد ذوي القصف في اوكرانيا بشكل غير
مسبوق فالحرب هناك تدخل مرحله جديده من
التصعيد والامر حسب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
نفسها اصبح مرعبا سماء اوكرانيا شهدت 43
صاروخا روسيا في هجمات متواصله تقول قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه متحدثه عن اسقاط 36
منها
العاصمه كييف وحدها استهدفت ب 20 صاروخا
ما اسفر عن اصابه عده اشخاص وتضرر مباني
ومنشات مختلفه القصف طال مقاطعه شركه
جنوبي كييف ايضا وفي غربي اوكرانيا تعرضت
مقاطعه ريفني لهجوم مشابه اصاب منشاه
للطاقه ما ادى الى انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن نحو 400 مدينه وقريه بينها
مناطق في مقاطعه كييف اما في الفيف غربان
فقد سقط صاروخان على منطقه درهوبيتش ما
ادى الى تدمير منشاه صناعيه ومخزن
الهجوم الروسي الكثيف خصوصا على منشات
الطاقه يجعل الصوره اكثر تهديدا اذ حذرت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه من اشهر وصفتها
بالصعبه في اعقاب الهجوم فمع قرب حلول فصل
الشتاء تخشى السلطات في كييف تكرار روسيا
استراتيجيه اعتمدتها عام 2022 وقامت
بالاساس على استهداف منشات الطاقه من اجل
قطع الكهرباء والتدفئه عن السكان وللمره
الاولى منذ سته اشهر تضررت منشات للطاقه
في غرب اوكرانيا ووسطها ورغم اعتراض
القوات الاوكرانيه غالبيه الصواريخ حسب
اعلانها الا ان عددا منها حقق اصابات
مباشره على الارض في مقابل الهجمات
الروسيه اعلن جهاز الامن المركزي
الاوكراني توجيه ضربه للقوات الروسيه في
مطار ساكي العسكري في شبه جزيره القرم وهو
احدث هجوم على المنطقه الواقعه على البحر
الاسود والتي تعهدت كييف باستعادتها في
مقابل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار اف شالها لما تعهدت به اوكرانيا
عبر تدمير 19 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
شبه جزيره القرم واكدت ان قواتها اسقطت
ايضا ثلاثه طائرات مسيره فوق مقاطعات
كورسيك